[Música]
eu sou liu sou violinista professora de
violino e viola da universidade federal
do ceará é um prazer estar aqui e hoje o
meu tema é música e esperança
eu escolhi esse tema porque acredito
firmemente no poder da música para
transformação social
a transformação das nossas realidades e
você pode participar disso
quando eu comecei a minha carreira e me
deparei com algumas dúvidas existenciais
que todo violinista e professor de
música se depara no começo são dúvidas
que causa uma baixa autoestima
na nossa profissão porque nessa
realidade que nós vivemos essa sociedade
que vivemos muitas vezes a música
encarado como um entretenimento algo de
menos importância e as perguntas que eu
tive que me preparar e responder pra
continuar minha caminhada foram pra que
serve a música pra quem eu vou tocar a
minha música ou ensinar a música por que
eu devo ensinar violino numa realidade
onde muitas pessoas sequer conhecem o
que é o violino e será que ensinar esse
repertório erudito de mozart beethoven
que tantos é caracteriza a música
erudita da onde vem a técnica do
instrumento será que isso realmente
importa pra quem importa
então eu tive a grata oportunidade de
participar como professora de um projeto
social em são paulo esse projeto social
é um dos projetos sociais maiores que
nós temos no brasil atualmente chamado
projeto guri nesse projeto
eu tive então uma experiência única como
professora eu estava me formando na
a escola de comunicações e artes da usp
então eu comecei a trabalhar nesse
projeto e vocês podem ver que neste site
do estado de são paulo existe uma
citação pequena sobre um evento que
ocorreu em 1995 esse evento aconteceu
dentro da febem de tatuapé
hoje não existe mais a febem mas a
fundação casa e eu era então professora
de ensino coletivo de violino dentro
desse projeto
nós tivemos então uma turma bem grande
de 40 alunos com vários professores e
dessa turma
nós tivemos um trabalho magnífico porque
esses jovens que estavam nesse momento
da vida eles participavam por livre e
espontânea vontade e eles eram muito
interessados
porém depois de um semestre de aulas com
apresentações maravilhosas
esse grupo se apresentou inclusive no
auditório cláudio santoro no festival
campos do jordão
nós tivemos uma rebelião então nessa
febem e foi uma rebelião violenta uma
rebelião há onde queimaram absolutamente
tudo e na violência daqueles jovens que
haviam cerca de dois mil jovens nesse
quadrilátero da fenda de tatuapé
eles queimaram os telhados os colchões
destruíram absolutamente todas as
habitações e nós os professores fomos
obrigados a esperar a poeira baixar
esperar a situação ser contida então era
uma situação extremamente difícil
quando tudo acabou nós os professores
pensamos seis meses de trabalho perdidos
porque depois de uma situação dessas
como é que se continua deve estar tudo
destruído quando foi a nossa surpresa
quando ao voltarmos para o trabalho nós
percebemos que o único galpão que não
tinha sido
edu era da música todas as outras
oficinas foram destruídas mas o da
música resistiu
então alguém bem intencionado perguntou
mas não muito feliz essa pergunta mas
perguntaram para os jovens
vocês destruíram tudo porque não
destruirá cigarro faltam em e eles
responderam porque durante os vários
dias da rebelião os jovens da música
estavam conosco os fizeram um cordão de
isolamento em torno do galpão e não
permitiram que a fúria dos demais
colegas invadissem aquilo que era deles
aquele galpão representava algo que era
deles
lá estavam os instrumentos os violinos
violas violoncelos e contrabaixos as
partituras aonde nós tocávamos o tema da
nona de beethoven asa branca brilha
brilha estrelinha que é um tema de
mozart e aquilo fazia tudo ser muito
significativo
depois dessa experiência eu entendi que
a música ela não tem limites que impõe
os limites muitas vezes somos nós mas a
música ela consegue penetrar nos
corações de todos hermano
então depois da experiência onde esses
jovens defenderam com as suas próprias
vidas
esse patrimônio eu entendi que o
instrumento violino ele serve para
trazer justamente essa possibilidade de
vida e de esperança para essas pessoas
para todos nós
então em 2015
vim pra cá pra fortaleza por meio do
concurso da universidade federal e
começamos então as turmas de extensão é
de violino e viola
junto com a minha colega dora quiroz
trabalha com o violoncelo e contrabaixo
começamos então nossas turmas de
extensão
essa primeira turma vocês vão ver são
poucos alunos ainda em 2015 seguido
então de uma apresentação em novembro de
2015 com cerca de 20 alunos participando
bem no nosso início vamos ter depois de
agosto a dezembro então uma turma com 20
pessoas participando no instituto de
cultura e arte em 2016 a camerata de
cordas eo fc foi criada essa câmera ata
se é serve para que os alunos tanto da
gravação quanto de extensão possa
desenvolver o seu lado artístico todos
os nossos cursos de extensão são
gratuitos e qualquer pessoa da
comunidade pode participar
essa foto que vocês estão vendo a
camerata participou então da campanha de
setembro amarelo de prevenção ao
suicídio na praça do ferreira também os
jovens tocaram nos lugares mais nobres
da cidade como o theatro josé de alencar
tudo isso em 2016 e nós tivemos então já
um número maior de participantes cerca
de 70 pessoas neste ano então de 2016 a
camerata realizou nove concertos com
alcance estimado de mais de mil pessoas
no público e em 2017 criamos mais
coragem e abrimos as nossas primeiras
turmas infantis
as primeiras turmas infantis tiveram uma
boa visão das crianças e adolescentes
aqui vocês podem ver eles praticando
exercícios ainda sem o instrumento e
depois nós vamos ter as apresentações na
seara da ciência no fc em junho de 2017
esse trabalho vem transformando o
panorama da cidade porque sim 2015 nós
não encontravam nos violinos pequenos na
cidade para comprar hoje em dia você vê
até no comércio é as pessoas expondo os
velhinhos pequenos graça esse
trabalho que é o sc oferece à comunidade
ao final de 2017 120 alunos com duas
urnas adultas e infantis a camerata mais
do que dobra a número de concelhos 43
concertos para um público estimado de 7
mil pessoas no ano passado em 2018
nós criamos a orquestra de cordas da
uece que é uma ampliação então dessas
turmas gratuitas da extensão
vem gente de todo canto da cidade
fizemos uma apresentação em junho de
2018 no theatro josé de alencar
e esse time e esse dia nós lotamos o
palco tanto que não havia mais espaço os
alunos tiveram que tocar até nos
corredores
nós temos visto então um crescimento do
interesse do público da cidade é em
estudar os instrumentos de cordas
camerata de cordas também abriu o jogo
do ceará e flamengo isso em 2018 foi no
na no castelão e a em dezembro de 2018
fizemos um concerto na concha acústica
então dá ué ser com participação de mais
de 270 músicos na orquestra com tudo
isso esse trabalho vem crescendo vem
tomando então cortou e as pessoas das
cidades nem tem conhecido como é que a
uefs e interage com a comunidade através
dos cursos de extensão
neste ano então de 2018 realizamos 44
concertos um público estimado de 58 mil
pessoas em 2019
abrimos novas turmas de 100 são sim 2018
tivemos 500 pessoas na inscritas este
ano mais do que dobrou e recebemos 1.314
inscrições e desse público todo tivemos
essa reunião de 11 de fevereiro agora
com a recepção então dos novos alunos
lá no instituto d
a artista vai ser
podemos ver que realmente o interesse do
público é muito grande pelas pela música
de concerto pelos instrumentos eruditos
e essa é uma das nossas nove turmas de
violino e viola
então espero que todos possam vir nos
conhecer
muito obrigada estamos no instituto de
artes a o fc e temos duas páginas no
facebook camerata de cordas artes e
ensino coletivo de cordas
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
o pé
[Aplausos]
tocamos primavera de vivaldi um símbolo
de esperança e agora vamos focar o tema
de viagem de chihiro um anime com
arranjo de nascer saldanha
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]